Bre TAKE LK ATHE MAP
WH I HPENI SE THING
A LILE BIT OF RSIANOVEMT
IN THE SOU.
LOTF BOMBAMENT CTINUES
SUBUSROUN KYISHISALL IN THE
SSIA MOVEMEN CONNUESSE
HA SEEN FOR MAN DAYS TO T
ENCCLE THE CITITY.
WHAT W HAV SNSIGNICANT
RAIAN PHBACK HER INHE
TY OF OSKIR ABOUT 16 LES
FR T CENR OYIV.
TA LOO ATHIS VID.THIS
IT I JNIFE GFFIN PIE.ED
GETTG H BY AI-NK
WEAPS.
OK A THIS.
THISTREE TS ARE JUSTO TE
TSID OF KV.
TTIN ATTACKE BY UAINI
RCES
NO WE WIL GO BK T T MAP.
AN TE YOU T ANOER PLA,
ICH ISIGHTN T OTHER
SIDETH IBO 45 LESSHE
CROWLIESUTSIHE CY OF
ANDNOTHAJ UKRNIAN
FENSE MOV TAK A LOOKTHE
VIDETH IS,GAINNTI-NK,
AN-ARM WEAPONS
LIKE A JELAKIN OUTARR RHT TRE.
'S HAPNING ALLHE TIM
THES 17,00PLUSAVELINS
THIS CNTRYTH IS A LOOK AT T ROAN
UKRAE ALHROUOUT.
REFUES N IHEINISR OUT
OF T COUNTRY
W,T'S MOR TN 300IL
OM KV T THEOLIS BORR.
TAKING 16,8 HOURS WE' TOL
D IS JT INTO O
FUGE.
LVIVHERE